Carol, I'd, I'd start with you. do you have any
personal opinion about gene patenting, or the idea of, you
know, can a company own a gene, specifically you know,
the bracket gene has been the subject of much debate?
>> myriad genetics was just denied the right
to patent the BRCA mutation, and I agree with
that completely.
>> Why is that?
>> Well, I don't, I don't, I think this information should be available,
and you don't patent the gene. A treatment, or medicine, for a period
of time, but the gene is, is something that we have in our body.
You know it's part of human nature, it's our human, in your human,
it's part of your makeup. And I don't think that they should
be able to patent a gene. All living things have genes. Trees.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Have cells with DNA in them. Cats, dogs, bacteria, what do
you think about patenting those genes. Do you feel similarly, or, differently.
>> I mean, it would, I think, the way that the decision
went, so that you can't patent something that's
already naturally occurring, I think that's already, that's been
in the law for a long time. I think
when you get into the recombinate DNA technology and
Bioengineering where you're changing the genetic code of
something. That, is currently allowed to be patented and
I think innovations like that should definitely, those are
pure innovations that deserves patents that should be protected.
>>
[COUGH]
>> Even if it's only one letter change? That one letter change, yeah,
if that one letter change changes the essence or the function of, I
mean, like I said, my wife's a yeast geneticist. So small changes make
big differences, so if you can change something like that, then that's a novel.
>> Sure.
>> Then true sickle cell anemia, one small change.
>> Mm-hm. BRCA mutation, and FGFR3 mutation
that can have major effects. I saw Sterling nodding
his head over there. You, you agree with that assessment?
>> Yeah. I would just think, like, an analogy, like can you patent like a type
of leaf, or you know, patent a part of your body. patent the
liver. I mean, this is something that's sort of occurring within nature,
already, and then to claim it, is a hard thing to buy into.